i was uh very pleased to see that you  and steve martin  picked up professionally he wrote a play  and personally  and personally you hooked up with him no  no but uh  talk to me about that i read that  sometimes during the play you would yell  at the audience is that true  yes you did yes you would break  character the night they filmed it  for the link you know they put in the  lincoln center performing arts library  for the archives he uh they're i mean  the front row i'm in the middle of a  monologue  this guy opens up peanut m m's  and those are especially loud at the  packaging yeah  just and rustling and i just i look at  him  in the middle of the monologue and i go  peanut m  m's oh and he looks but you know he he  was really sweet he looks at me and he's  like  realized yeah he put him away but you  know when i sit and when i  you you bastard did that annoys steve  was he like hey you can't do that no  he mean he was very grateful and like  really sweet about everything